So use the term psychoactive. You might wonder what is psychoactive? Well,
psychoactive drugs are any drug that affect or change mood, cognition or
behavior. So, for example, cocaine is a psychoactive drug. It changes mood, it
improves cognition, it makes one think and feel powerful, like a competent
person and behavior. It increases motor activity. However, cocaine is not
prescribed for any of these things. Now, that leads us to psychotropic drugs.
These are drugs that are prescribed, this is the key, to affect or change mood,
cognition, or behavior. So, an antidepressant, such as an SSRI, as we learned
about in Lesson 3, are prescribed to affect and change mood, cognition, and or
behavior. That makes anti depressants psychotropic drugs.